darkness loomed over the streets of
night city the shadows casting long
shadows over the cracked asphalt
pavement the city's dark darkness
lurking deep within its shriveled black
hearts as black as pitch and a shriveled
as the lungs of a chain-smoking sailor
Joe knife pinned the girl up against the
wall his ugly slobbering face smearing
as a smearing Li pulled up her skirt
don't worry he sneered I'll make sure
this hurts a lot I'm a rapist this is
what I do
rape in things like that it was then
that he was clobbered by a bowl of
chowder steaming hot and packed with
delicious clams and white potatoes
cooked just to firmness with a few
celery bits as well to give it snap and
flavor it was New England clam chowder
for the figure who stood on the rooftop
wearing a black apron and a tall chef's
hat made of black cloth was not fond of
tomatoes in his clam chowder and
considered in an aberration nay a heresy
which must be purged Joan I screamed in
pain as he raised his gun and fired it
at the rooftop but the black clad
mysterious figure was too fast for him
and vanished in a flash of black cloth
come out he screamed who the hell are
you where the [ __ ] are you coming from
right here said a voice and pounded him
in the back of the skull with a ladle
Joe knife grabbed the back of his head
oh it hurts he shouted and you didn't
answer my question
oh I you the mysterious stranger drew
himself up to his full mysterious seven
feet of height and the grin on his face
was wide and mysterious moonlight
glinted off the horns on his forehead
the name is clef he said chowder Claire
defender of the world